foreign
have you ever wondered how facial
recognition works on social media or how
object detection helps in building
self-driving cars or how disease
detection is done using visual imagery
in healthcare it's all possible thanks
to convolutional neural network CNN
hello everyone I am mayank and welcome
to Simply learn today we will take you
through our hands of live demo of how we
can use CNN model for image
classification in machine learning
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
let's wait sir four more minutes to let
other people join until then let me tell
you guys that we have regular updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will discuss what CNN
model is and moving ahead we will
discuss how does CNN recognize images
after that we will see layers in CNN
at the end we will do a hands of layer
demo of image classification using CNN
in fact according to its statistics
there will be more than 2.3 million job
opening in the field of artificial
intelligence and machine learning by
2023 but you can beat the curve with our
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning co-sponsored by
Purdue University and IBM that is
designed after simply learn intense
bootcamp learning model Ai and ml
certification course this course covers
tools and techniques like python
tensorflow KRS nltk matplotlib
Alexa dijango along with the industry
projects like Twitter social media
zomato delivery service provider Uber
transportation service provider and many
amazing projects choosing this course
you can get hired by renowned companies
like Google Amazon Microsoft Adobe
Airbus Deloitte and an average salary
hike of 70 percent so what are you
waiting for join the AI and ml
professional certificate program and
Excel your career in artificial
intelligence the link is in the
description box below don't forget to
check it out so before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss what CNN
is and proceed further for the same so
what is CNN a convolutional neural
network is a feed forward neural network
that is generally used to analyze visual
images by processing data with grid-like
topology
it also known as con net convolutional
neural network CNN is used to detect and
classify object in an image imagine
there is a image of a bird and you want
to identify whether it's a really bird
or some other object the first thing you
do is feed the pixels of the images in
the form of arrays to the input layer of
the neural network the hidden layer
carries out the feature extraction by
performing different calculation and
manipulation so there are multiple
hidden layers like the convolutional
layer the value layer the pooling layer
and the perform feedback section from
the image so finally finally there is a
fully connected layer that identifies
the object in the image okay so moving
forward let's see how does CNN recognize
images so
the boxes a color represent a pixel
value of one and zero if are not colored
okay I'm repeating again the boxes that
are colored represent a pixel value of 1
and 0 if not colored when you press
backslash the image get processed okay
and when you press forward slash the
image gets processed
okay so let's take another example to
depict how CNN recognize images
so this is a real image
so
this is the representation of the form
of black and white pixels okay of the
images
so moving forward so this image
represent in the form of Matrix of a
number
so as you can see from the these
diagrams only those values are lit that
have a value of 1. okay
so moving forward let's see layers in
convolutional neural network CNN a CNN
has multiple hidden layers that help in
extracting information from an image
there are three important layers in CNN
first convolutional layer second the
relu layer third the pooling layer so
first one is convolution layer this is
the first step in the process of
extracting valuable features from an
image a convolutional layer has several
filters that perform the convolutional
operations
every image is considered as a matrix of
pixel values
so consider the following 5 into 5 image
whose pixels values are either 0 or 1.
there is also a filter Matrix with a
dimension of three by three side
the filter Matrix over the images and
compute the dot product to get convolved
feature Matrix
okay then second one is relu layer
so Railway stands for rectified linear
unit once the feature Maps extracted the
next step is to move them to a relu
layer the relu performs an element wise
operation and sets all the negative
pixel to zero
it introduced non-linearity to the
network and the generated output is a
rectified feature map
So Below is this is the graph of value
function okay and the below is the
equation and the third one is pooling
layer so pooling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the future map
the rectified feature map now goes
through a pooling layer to generate a
pool feature map
the pulling layer uses various filters
to identify different parts of image
like edges corners body feathers eyes
and Brake okay so now let's move to the
programming part so this is a python
kernel so here first we will change the
name
pnn for beginners
okay
so first what we will do we will import
some major libraries here
like numpy pandas tensorflow
first we will import some major
libraries so here I will write import
numpy
as NP
okay
then second one
is import
ant
as PD
and import
matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
then import
c bond
as SNS
then import
Keras
tensorflow
sensorflow here
dot Keras
okay so now let's run it
still loading okay
Okay small
still loading yeah it's perfect so
number is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working within the domain
of lineal algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely number stand for numerical python
pandas panda is a software Library
written for the path programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structure and operation for manipulating
numerical tables at the time series
and the third one in matplotlib
for Python and its numerical extension
number matplotlib is a cross-platform
data visualization and graphical
charting package
so as a result it present a strong open
source substitute for Matlab the apis
like apis means application programming
interface what matte broadly allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
Gia applications
and the Sea bone this one
okay
so C bone is a python data visualization
Library based on matplotlip it provides
a high level interface for drawing
attractive and informative statical
graphics
so for a brief introduction to the ideas
behind the library
so
you can go to our simplylearn.com
website and check there
US is an open source software library
that provides a python Library interface
for artificial neutral network errors
act as interface for the tensorflow
library
supported multiple backends including
tensorflow Microsoft cognitive toolkit
piano and played ml
tensorflow
tensorflow is a free and open source
software library for machine learning
and AI it can be used across a range of
tasks but has a particular focus on
training and inference of deep neural
networks
okay got it
so moving forward what we will do we
will load the data set so here we we are
using mnist dataset which is based on
clothing okay so there are 10 different
classes of images like t-shirt trouser
pullover dress code sandal shirt sneaker
bag ankle boot
okay
and image is in 28 into 28. so fashion
mnis consists of 60 000 training images
and 10 000 test image
it is a mnisd like fashion product
database the developers believe mnist
has been overused so they created this a
direct replacement for the data set each
image is in grayscale and associated
with a label for the 10 classes okay I
discuss about like dresses like sandals
shoes trousers and all these are the 10
classes each image is 28 pixels is in
height and 28 pixel in width I already
said 28 by 28 so for a total 784 pixel
in total okay
each pixel has a single Pixel value
associated with it indicating the
lightness or the darkness of that pixel
with the higher
meaning
this pixel value is in integer value
between 0 and 255.
okay
so here we will load the data and we
will split the data into training and
the testing set
on the same end okay so here I will
write
strain
by train
test
comma y test
it was true
errors
dot data set
dot fashion
administ
dot load
did
okay
so the data is loaded okay so load data
is used for the loading the data
so now let's see like how many rows and
columns present in the training section
and the
like in the extreme and the Y train then
we'll see for the testing for the same
okay so here I will write X train
dot shape
there is no need I guess
for this comma
y train
dot tape
okay
see we have 60 000
rows and 28 columns for a particular
data set
okay
now
X
test dot shape
comma y
test dot a
error in the testing we have 10 000 rows
and 28 columns I already told you before
when I talked about the data set like we
have 60 000 training images at that 10
000 testing images
okay
so
and if you want this full code I will
provide you in the description box below
just comment for the same that you want
the full code
okay so now let's train
the data
then X
train
the label y
y
and let's see this
okay
so what I will do with better visuals I
will do like this so now let's see for
the show images so here I will set the
class labels
class
tables
t-shirt
t-shirt or it can be top
okay then trousers
and
pull over
dress
then quote
then standard
but
sneakers
then
back
ankle wood
let's see some images
so what
yeah
I will write class
no no
I will add PLT dot show
next train
comma C map
so
great
to see it is a ankle boot let's look
like an angle boat
let's see one more
okay PLT dot I am sure
strain
emap
equals to Grace
okay it is a t-shirt
we have 60 000 images in the trading set
so we can check the any
let's see one more BLT dot I am show
strain
foreign
Grace
there's a shoe
okay let's copy it
the last we are checking
for the 50.
something dress
okay
so this is it for the training that is
why we are writing here x strain
right
so
now let's see the all the categories
okay like sneaker ankle boot code and
t-shirt okay
sandal and all
so for that I will write here PLT Dot
figure
size
I will give 16 by 16.
okay
equals to one
for I
n
NP dot random
Dot Rand and
0 comma
ten thousand
30 000 only 25
LT dot subplot
F comma five
comma J
Plus
two one
PLT dot I am sure
X strain
I
my cmapped
equals to what Grace
okay
then Pat dot X is
of
and PLT dot title
again calibrances
but I will write here
Dot format
us
by train
one
y train
okay so now let's see run it
okay so there is an error
object has no property cap okay
it is cmap
see now you can see the sneaker bag
pullover sandal dress
so all the categories okay short code
bag sticker this is for the training the
trousers we are training
all the images
okay for the model
so now what we will do we will reshape
some
training data
okay the length and the testing data
length
okay so moving forward we will do that
let's
do
the reshaping and on
so fashion
um
S2 KRS
dot data sets
dot passion
right here
X strain
a white train
comma
X test
fashion
extreme
these dimensions
so here I will write X strain
minus one
okay or we can write X strain equals to
Extended reshape length x strip
okay
uh here I will write X test
equals to NP Dot expand
dimensions
X test
comma minus 1.
okay here I will let
a one
plus two
NP dot add a
D dot unique
a train
1 equals to
and here I will write
boy
I hit one
then EA index
one
or append
append to list
y train
Dot
index
I
okay then print
text
one
okay so cross check for I in index print
white and I okay so here I will write
PLT dot figure
because size
was true
twenty four more twenty four
okay four
X comma y
and
enumerate
index one
this
and I will add print
extreme
dot shape
then PLT dot subplot
2 comma 5
comma
X Plus 1
LT dot I am show
tensorflow
who is
an X strain
why
was to Grace
PhD Dot title
dot comet
K1
thanks
okay X strain and P dot index
so they expand
hips X strain minus one
okay okay
valid index
what I wrote here let me check
import numpy as NP
the errors
okay let me check the other
working
these are the 10 category
okay
these are the pixel size
28 into 28
okay
so moving forward what we will do we
will change the dimensions
okay and then after that we will do the
feature scaling
okay for the changing dimension
so we'll do X string
dot ending
3 means three dimension image this one
is the three dimension image
then
Extreme Dot shape
is 60 000 then what I will do
next train
equals to NP
Dot
expand
screen
comma minus 1.
just
pursue
NP dot expand
test comma
minus 1.
so four dimension image X
strain
m
okay
end him
this is a four dimension image okay the
next
chain
or shape
okay fine
so now what we will do we will do the
feature scaling
so for the feature scaling I will write
here x strain
equals to
X strain
by 255.
okay
here I will write X test question
X test
bye
so what is feature Skilling feature
scaling is a method used to normalize
the range of independent variables or
features of the data so in data
processing it is also known as the data
normalization
and is generally performed during the
data preprocessing steps
okay
so
let's see the data is in 0 to 1 for that
right here small small code X strain
in
zero
so now what we will do we will split the
data set for the validation set
okay for that we will write here from
SK learn
dot model
selection
import
then
Trust
that's it
strain
go
X
value
comma y train
y value
first you train
test
it
and here I will write dentist split then
okay
split then I will write here
extreme
comma y train
my best
oh
okay oh my skin long
over here now I will write X strain
dot shape
white train
shape
8000 okay then x value
dot shape
comma y value
okay twelve thousand see our total
images in exchange were sixty thousand
so now we will we did the train touch
split okay so test size is 0.2 so we're
split into like 80 and 20
okay
so that is where there are 48 000 images
so now we'll make
CNN model okay convolutional neural
network so for the convolutional front
end we can start with the like three
conversion layer with a small filter
size and modest number of filters okay
followed by a Max pooling layer the
filter Maps can be the flat end to
provide features to the classifier okay
so
we know that we required an output layer
with like 10 nodes in order to predict
the probability distribution of an image
belonging to each of the 10 classes this
is also require use of sort Max
activation function between the feature
extractor and the output layer
we can add a dense layer to interpret
the feature in this case with the 128
nodes
okay so listen that like all layers will
use the relu activation function and the
weight initialization scheme like both
best practices
what we will do we will
create
model
okay
so
so this is the code
for the model
okay so in this we use the layers these
are the three layers layer one layer two
layer three okay
so as I said to you we will start from
the max pooling layer
okay
so
here we used units equals to 128. and
activation equals to relu
okay
and there is dance Dance Again the layer
so
Max pooling here is a term Max pulling
2D
so it is a pooling or Max pooling
operation which calculates the largest
or the maximum value in every patch and
and in the every features
okay
so it is used in the pooling operation
that calculates the maximum value for
the patches
and to create the pool feature map
got it
and here is a dense
so uh dance is like in any neural
network a denser is a layer that is
deeply connected with the presenting
preceding layer so which means the
neurons of the layer are connected to
every neuron of its preceding layer the
layer is mostly commonly used in
artificial neural network
okay
and there is
dropouts like
how much
it will be drop out for every
you know layers from every layers
there is one more word
flatten so flattening is used to convert
all the resultant two-dimensional array
from pole feature map into a single long
continuous linear vector
the flattened Matrix is fed as input to
the fully connected layer to the
classify image
okay
this soft Max is a like equation
or a function you use to activation
function in the output layer of the
neural network
and that predictor multinomiality
probability distribution that is softmax
is used as the activation function
okay
and relu is again
you know a particular layer
looking forward
to visuals
so now what we will do we will plot the
neural network for the workflow
okay
Keras Dot
else
plot model
to
find question
Dot
PNG
X
happening
show
tips
question
true
here I will write so
layer
custom
true
there is an error
okay
model is not defined so what we have to
do
we have to install here Pi Dot
okay pip install Pi Dot
and install graph with
okay so let me install and let I will
come back to you
so
here what I will write we'll see the
model dot summary
this is the model summary
okay
and now what we will do we will compile
and model fitting do the model fitting
so here I will do the model Dot
compile
optimizer
plus two
Adam
categorical
cross
rupee
okay
here I will add Matrix
question
okay
so now I will write model Dot fit
right here
let me delete this
order Dot
it
extreme
comma a box
was to
more badge
guys
was two Pi one two
comma verbose
to one
comma
validation
data
equals to X
well
comma y
okay
so it will take time it will run till
94. okay the laws that accuracy will
come so we have to wait for some more
minutes
till let it be complete
it will
Hotel 20
so I will get back to you when it will
be complete
almost 14 done 15 16 17 18 19 20 are
left
so we'll wait and we'll see
so any POG is when all the training data
is used at once and is defined as a
total number of iteration of all the
training data in one cycle for the
training and machine learning model
so another way to define a block is the
number of passes a training data set
takes around an algorithms
okay
we'll wait till 20
17.
three more left
they are the lower security and
validation laws
value loss
if you want this full code you can
comment and if you have been query
related to python machine learning or
anything
okay you can comment down
our team will
reach you as soon as possible
so
two more 19 and 20.
you raise your model accuracy is good 93
if you have any query you can comment
down below okay 19 is done
final 20 is going on epoch
you can enroll in our
course of AI and ml you can check the
link in the description box below
using course
after this we will test the model then
we will do evaluation
then confusion mesh tricks and then
visualizing of the output the final
output
okay
yeah so it's done
so now let's test the model testing of
the model
so now let's start the testing the model
okay
so here I will write
model dot predict
happy
Dot
expand
okay
X
test
at zero axis
round is how many decimal points okay
so now
NP dot ARG Max
and
model
dot predict
NP dot expand
times
X test
this will be zero
[Music]
dot round
added two
okay
access
not okay
so here I have to write exit close to
zero
okay
so now cross check
white test
zero
same
okay
then
why
prediction
equals to model
dot predict
and
ACT test
to
prediction
so now we will evaluate so model Dot
evaluate
dot evaluate
test
comma y
okay
so now let's do the model evaluation
so accuracy given by train set is 0.94
which is very good 94 and accuracy given
by test set is 90 so thus we can say
that our model is generalized so no
overlifting or not underfitting okay so
now confusion Matrix
so from SK learn
Dot
Matrix
port
confusion
Matrix
okay then PLT Dot
figure
then figure size
let's do
16 comma 9
y underscore prediction
by prediction
NP Dot
ARG Max
label
or
label and
y prediction
then cm
confusion Matrix equals to
confusion
tricks
by test
I
prediction
labels
okay
so
now
we will write
will grade heat map SNS Dot
heat map
Vision metrics
comma a naught
was true true
then fmt
equals to
d
comma
X stick
labels
so
class
dot labels
then
y tick
level
was to
class levels
okay
is another
yeah see the heat map is game
okay this for the T-shirt pullover dress
code and here also
okay
so
now
we will visualize the output
so PLT dot so it is like coming correct
or not okay expected and predicted okay
or you can say the actual and predicted
so PLT dot figure
size
16 comma 30
equals to 1
or I
and NP Dot
random
Dot dependent
comma
60.
PLT dot subplot
text comma
okay
then here I will write J plus 1
.
and PLT Dot
I am show
X test
I
e shape
it's 28 height and width
and cmap equals to Grace
PLT dot access
of
PLT dot title
foreign
equals to
slash n
addicted
pursue
dot format
because labels
my test
all right
but
be
the max
bye
predicted is I
then will write NB Dot
ARG Max
I
predicted
press enter
loading
so
as you can see actually this t-shirt
shop t-shirt and top then predicted you
also fine
okay some error then trousers are same
sandals are same ankle boot also same
so as you can see here
some are right and some are wrong
T because the testing accuracy is 90 the
predicted accuracies that the training
accuracy is 94 percent that is why okay
so this is
the CNN of image classification how you
can use
and if you have any queries related any
code or you want this full code you can
ask me in the comment section okay I
will provide you the full code so mostly
the related and actual are coming till
then everything is coming good so I hope
you guys understand till here if you
have any question or any query regarding
any code a question just put us in
comments our team will surely provide
you the correct solution
so I hope you guys have much understood
the concept of CNN what is CNN what is
how CNN recognize images
and
that thing so
thank you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this video please do subscribe
to our YouTube channel and give a like
to this video till then thank you and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you